out of all the dumb [ __ ] that I [ __ ]
have done like I probably regret this
the most what do you think is the level
of frustration from fans other
influencers I check my phone and there's
a message a group message that says
do we need to get crisis management
involved I said that I didn't do this
thing I said that I didn't do steroids
this whole time when you say something
like this what do you think upset them
the most I feel that I've been disloyal
I feel like I have betrayed I think that
this is probably the sentiment that I
betrayed them you understand the pain
that they would this is what I'm saying
like I feel like I let a whole
generation down to look your your kids
in the eye and to tell them that you've
been lying to them you know I've never
lied to my kids about anything but I
lied to them about this you see the pain
the fan is going to get if they think
they can never be like you I'm not a
good son I'm not a good brother I'm not
even a good friend it's like you know
what I'm I'm good to myself let me tell
you one thing about America here's what
America is all about for whatever reason
Americans theme seen a man fall and be
publicly humiliated he says well you
know what Americans love more I said
what
all right so we got a special podcast
here for you with a man named Brian
Johnson but you know him as a liver King
and he's been uh you know he he was with
a friend of ours earlier today he's now
in uh just flown from New York to talk
about some of the things that's been
going on so with that being said Brian
thank you for being on the podcast man
I'm so grateful to be here you know
normally I get really excited and giddy
to get on a podcast to talk about
ancestral living to do some goddamn good
in the world and I know that's not why
hopefully we get a pepper some of this
in hopefully we get to talk about we're
going to definitely get some of that in
as well yeah there's no question about
that but dude just looking at you right
now you look like an animal just so you
know that I mean I've been around
bodybuilders for a long time your body
looks like somebody who's ready to
compete I appreciate it I I do
um I think as we get more into this
podcast you'll see for me it's so much
deeper than that um but you know also I
know that I'm here today because I [ __ ]
[ __ ] up yep you know I own that and I
know we're going to talk about that that
um I apologize for that and I'm really
here to to talk about and to move
forward so so why don't we start off
with that and then we can get into all
the topics that we want to get into so
you know about a year ago maybe even
nine months ago we start seeing you
everywhere okay we might myself just
like everybody hey did you hear about
the lyric engineer about the living zero
people I'm like wow what's he talking
about so he talking about liver you got
to eat this and you got to eat bone
marrow I'm like dude that's great being
Middle Eastern you know I've been
waiting for somebody to promote liver
because nobody likes to eat liver with
me so I'm like another guy that likes
eating liver and he's not from Iran or
he's not Armenia serious so that part of
it was great so and then uh you know as
you're on podcast whether it's with
whoever it is you're like yeah I don't
do steroids PD let me tell you I did
take PD I'm gonna admit to it and you
said the lines that you said and then uh
came the part from the rest of us uh I
mean I've been around bodybuilders for a
long time my dream was to be Mr Olympia
when I was a kid coming out I went to
the military like that's what I was
going to do and I'm looking at your body
just like like everybody else who's in
the space
and saying you know just naturally it's
it's not possible to look like that guy
right there and and then the story comes
out last week about the stuff that you
were taking in an email uh if you want
to put that up there Rob when you see in
the email well you know this email and
that this was taken and that was taken
and this was taken and for people that
are in the space they know what those
things are you know you know it yourself
if you're into space You Know It uh I
come from a background where uh in
bodybuilding back in the days there was
the steroids Bible Edition one and the
second one and the third one and they
would always change the color I remember
back in the days with uh Bill Phillips
from muscle media 2000 who was always
the guy that would be straight up and it
was very uh random for people to come
out talking about steroids he was one of
the first guys I said no I used steroids
here's what I do and then Arnold did it
so for me when I saw you not doing it
the first thing I thought about was the
final one there used to be a time 30
years ago if somebody smoke weed you're
like oh that guy smokes weed he must be
a gangster he must be this today he you
smoke weed nobody gives a [ __ ] like
literally no one cares if you go on the
street somebody next to you smoking when
I was like smoking weed great
and and I think we're getting to a phase
where steroids if a person chooses to do
it
for whatever reason they want to do it
there's some studies that say you ought
to do it your trt levels your
testosterone levels are low this this
that I think we're getting to a level
where it's no longer a big deal but you
kept saying I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm
not I'm not and I'm boom this comes out
and the world hears about it I've heard
your video where you talk about this but
maybe share with us you know when you
first saw this email that came out and
the world saw it what was your immediate
reaction
when you saw that and then your mindset
when you're making a video to talk to
the world who's been thinking you've not
been using steroids your entire life
well I remember it like it was five
minutes ago
um I was getting ready to go to bed it's
probably 8 30. I just spent spent some
time with my boys and everything was
dark in the house I'm getting ready to
go to bed right before I go to bed I
like to just check my phone yeah make
sure there's no emergencies and um uh
there's this Pew that I sit at my house
it's nice and dark nobody can actually
see me they walk by they don't even know
I'm there and so I checked my phone and
there's a message a group message that
says
do we need to get crisis management
involved and I'm thinking oh God here we
go again like somebody's overreacting
and so
um you know I'm like what what are we
talking about here so somebody then
sends a link to the video and uh so I
start watching the video I'm like I've
already seen five of these from the same
guy like okay here we go again who was
the guy that you're talking about Derek
from more plates board dates has made
quite a few videos right gotcha and so
I'm all negative about you
you know I wouldn't even call them
negative I I would call them the truth
well you know there is one that's
totally [ __ ] full of [ __ ] it's about
me having AB implants and ab itching
like so I I will say that's completely
not true
um but uh
so so I'm like okay big deal here's
another video same guy right and then uh
so I say you know tell me exactly what
minute to go to so then I went to the
minute that they told me to go to and
then they start reading the email that I
sent and I said holy [ __ ] like I did
this you know I did this and I called my
wife over I'm like wife
she comes over she sits right next to me
so she doesn't have a name wife over her
eyes that's what I said wow I fell over
here bro you got Primal she comes over
and she starts watching it with me and I
think she could probably feel my heart
beating right next to her it was going
to come out of my chest and again like
everything on there was true and I said
okay like here we are right now we're
here and so my mindset is um I called
Derek uh and he didn't answer so that
sentiment text message I said hey man
thank you and so uh then he answered I
said hey what's the best way to get in
touch with you he said I'm free now so I
gave him a call and I said uh thank you
for doing this I don't know what good
will come of this but good bad and
different you know everything in life is
good and I'm gonna find a way you know
to make silver linings from this and so
there's so much good what was his
reaction when you saw like how did he
take it yeah well actually this is what
I what what he says hello and I said
how long did it take for you to make
this documentary and it he says a couple
of weeks and I said holy [ __ ] a couple
of weeks you did a masterful job hats
off to you thank you for doing this I
don't know what good will come but good
will come of this and it goes oh I'm
surprised that you're so chill about
this and I said well I don't know what
you expect me to be you know maybe you
expect something else but you know I
know that you know this too but like you
can't be grateful and express a life of
abundance and also scarcity and contract
at the same time like and so this is my
attitude these are my philosophies my
principles that that drive me I'm like
okay I don't know
how we're going to deal with this but
I'm grateful for this and I'm going to
figure my way you know into this well I
figured my way into that now now I gotta
like go through the storm and so that's
my mindset you know that's what I'm
thinking you know and so the way that I
came up with the apology video is just
like um the kids were going to bed they
went to bed uh first thing the next day
I said hey I need to talk to you guys
let's get around the table so we all got
around the table and really what I said
to my kids is almost the same thing on
the apology video was like I just looked
at them you know and uh this is tough
you know um
to look your your kids in the eye and to
tell them that you've been lying to them
you know I've never lied to my kids
about anything but I lied to them about
this
so I told them
um I said I lied to you guys you know
and what I did was wrong let me tell you
what I've lied about I have taken
steroids I'm on steroids right now and I
can tell you the reasons why I'm going
to justify it you deserve to know you
know why I've Justified it but what I
did was wrong and um I'll never lie to
you guys again and you know the reason
why I just the the mind is such a deadly
weapon because once I got myself into
this you know I convinced myself that
this had nothing to do with my message I
convinced myself that um
who the [ __ ] am I cheating like I'm not
in a competitive sport who am I cheating
you know and I would say like one of the
most hurtful things is um
or maybe I did some of the most damages
I convinced myself that the 15 year old
boy my kids these guys they don't need
to hear this message
and so um there's a whole lot of other
things that I'd convince myself of but
once I'd convince myself of like these
six or seven things I'm like digging the
hole and digging the hole you know now
I'm answering DMs I don't touch the
stuff Never Gonna touch this stuff don't
touch this you know now I'm going on
podcasts you know and now I'm doing the
same thing and I'm just digging that
[ __ ] hole deeper and deeper and
deeper you know and um
it's probably the the thing that I
regret most of my life out of all the
dumb [ __ ] that I [ __ ] have done like
I probably regret this the most so uh
facing my my kids what was um it was
tough
but um it's brought us closer together
and you know another Silver Lining that
I see in this is like you know my kids
have
helped me in the highest or they think
that on this infallible character and so
I will say that um I am grateful that my
kids see me drop to my [ __ ] knees
they see how I'm dealing with this you
know from day one I was grateful for it
um immediately I'm like I own this I
[ __ ] own this and I'm going to lead
myself out of this and I want you guys
to see what ends up happening I know I'm
not Rising above this now but I know in
time that that will happen and uh so
that's how I handled that all right so
today's podcast sponsored by Aura
aura.com I've been talking about these
guys a lot I fully believe everybody
needs to take advantage of their service
for a couple different reasons I've been
running a financial firm for a long time
and cyber attacks are a real thing it
doesn't just happen to business owners
it happens to individuals quite a lot
nowadays matter of fact the number one
crime in 2021 that cost the most was 52
billion dollars it's not home robber we
used to be number one now it's actually
cyber attacks there's people using your
password and this is why we decided to
uh team up and have uh Aura as one of
our sponsors so these are some of the
things that they do for you aura's
Identity Theft Protection fraud
monitoring a VPN password management and
anti-virus software all combined into
one easy to use app you may have one of
these tools but not having all of them
is like locking the front door but
leaving the back door wide open Aura
monitors a dark web for your emails
password and social security number and
sends alerts right to your phone and
email when it comes to fraud every
second matters connect your credit and
bank accounts and get notified of any
changes up to four times faster than
aura's competitors look a couple of our
guys already use this service and they
noticed their password was being used on
the dark web 42 times once at 44 times I
I challenge you to go out there and do
the test yourself and see how many times
yours is being used so protect you and
yourself from America's fastest growing
crime try Aura free for two weeks and
see if any of your or your family's
personal information has been
compromised start your free 14-day trial
at aura.com forward slash pbd once again
Aura a u r a.com forward slash pbd you
know I got tell you before we went live
on the camera you were talking about how
you know the life I lived that life a
mile away I live close I want to do this
because I worked so hard that I want to
spend time with the kids your kids are
here with you your wife's here with you
while you're going through this that
says a lot about the character of the
family and anything with family you know
you know issues like this there's not a
perfect father in the world there's not
a perfect mother in the world uh the
best thing I ever was taught about this
that lifted a lot of weight off my back
of having perfect expectations of my
parents was three things I learned a guy
one time told me this it says every kid
and a parent specifically father-son
relationship goes through three phases
first they idolize which you just use
the word they idolize that then they
demonize I can't believe you did the
stat which you haven't gone through your
sons are they have your back and the
last one is humanize that is a human
he's not a machine he's not perfect okay
so that level of him and that lifts
weight off our back to become looser
parent having fun you still have high
standards and expectation but I'm not
here to be perfect but let me let me
first of all thank you for being
transparent I feel the sincerity here
from you uh a lot more than the video I
watch I think the videos connected what
I say so much pressure like under so
much pressure when you look look at
something like this so you're trying to
say everything known there's going to be
you know you can't give the perfect
message specifically these types of mess
people are going to tear it apart and
they're going to say here and there but
a couple things I want to ask you is why
do you think uh you know why do you
think the public was uh uh frustrated
with the fact like how do you think the
public has felt because you said
something you said your line was look
before I was rich and Anonymous and then
after social media the last year now I'm
rich and famous maybe not those words
but in that context right that you said
I'm prefacing what you said
and that makes sense there's power in
being low-key and having your own life
and just kind of not getting bothered by
anybody can go anywhere I was at Beverly
Hills Hilton by the my wife's across the
street you're going to Beverly Hill
system will stand at the same Hotel I'm
going to the restaurant you're walking
in she's like babe did you see that guy
would I say yeah it's just Prime it's
liver King he's just walking in there
right four weeks ago five weeks ago you
were in L.A we were in LA but people now
recognize you everywhere you go but what
do you think is the level of frustration
from fans other influencers when you say
something like this what do you think
upset them the most
the relationship with you and the fan
you know fans when they run up to you
they feel like they've known you yeah
it's kind of like they were just kicking
it with you yes it's kind of weird when
you talk to a fan and a fan today is
very different than a fan of 20 years
ago the fan of 20 years ago is you only
see that Hollywood celebrity in a movie
so it's like oh my God it's Sylvester
Stallone but the fan today is he watches
you every day on a podcast every day on
Instagram every day on Tick Tock it's
not just a fan it's my boy yeah it's my
you know so what was what was what would
disappointment did you experience with
defense what do you think they're
thinking and and they really know me I
mean I I first thing I do I get up I
make a good morning Story I mean I'm
filming stories all throughout the day
every single day you know to let people
in yeah and I think uh I don't know how
really to answer this other than um I
let them all down you know um
I said that I didn't do this thing I
said that I didn't do steroids this
whole time you know and I've been doing
them and so I think that when you're
dishonest with with somebody when you
mislead somebody
um I believe that what they feel is
betrayed you know and and so what I try
to share back is
um
first thing I always want to say is I
apologize for this I did this I did this
um I own that and and I know what I did
was wrong but what I try and make sure
everybody understands is the North Star
is that 4 000 people today actually kill
themselves that 80 000 people a day try
that 85 percent of the population has
self-esteem issues 80 struggle paycheck
to paycheck and there's a reason right
like why do we live beyond our means
right why are we trying to project our
status our worth our potential with [ __ ]
that you put on your on your wrist with
what you caught with with the car that
you drive you know 70 of the population
is overweight half where obese 50 on
prescription medicine forty percent have
or will get cancer and 20 want to have
kids and can't have kids that minor star
is that the world is hurting at record
rates my kids couldn't breathe they had
to go by ambulance to the hospital year
after year after year ancestral living
was our Salvation And I know how badly
people are hurting right so I feel that
I've been disloyal I feel like I have
betrayed I think that this is probably
the sentiment that I betrayed them and
so what I try to share back is I just
ask for you to do two things you know
the the facts are the facts these
statistics I know how desperately people
are hurting and I believe with my heart
and soul that there's a better life it's
a simple way of living it's the
ancestral lifestyle so the the sentiment
you know that I'm getting from a lot of
people that I read is um hey Ben you let
me down I believed in you you let me
down
um I'm actually shocked at the favorable
sentiment that hey you know uh even
though you did this you were mad enough
to come forward here's how you've
changed my life and I'm like holy [ __ ]
man like I just start reading some of
these DMS and so many kids you know who
are living a better life and I'm like
well I gotta keep doing this that's a
powerful message by the way like
everything you just said about
being a better person and how much
people are struggling in depression like
if you just stuck with that message
right and just continued to work out and
didn't do steroids but still look like a
massive [ __ ] caveman animal
wouldn't the message still be as
powerful right like why do you need
steroids to to embrace that message yeah
the steroids aren't for the message the
steroids are for me you know um somebody
asked me hey cut all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
give it to me in one line I don't know
if this is one line but I think what it
really boils down to is number one over
training and number two in my self-worth
and and so what's required of me to go
to bed at night to look in the mirror
and be like hey man you're okay you're
worth it you earned it you did what you
need to do right to be your best
um for me to sleep okay at night I have
to put myself in the gym twice a day to
kill myself to crush myself to destroy
myself and it's at least twice a day
this is what I publicly say you know a
lot of times I'm getting in there a
third or a fourth time you know and and
that's what is required of being right
to feel like I did it you know I don't
know if you've ever gotten something
that you didn't earn and you know you
could have earned it and if that happens
over and over and over and so
um so for me this may a big difference
Peds made a difference for me to allow
myself to get into to maintain two of
these workouts a day and the dangerous
thing is after PDS I'm like oh [ __ ] I
can get in here maybe a third time maybe
a fourth time and so for the first time
today what I talked about is okay well
why do I need to do that you know some
someone asked me actually the other day
today's the first time I ever talked
about it and um and I've never dealt
with this before you know I don't really
I've never really believed that trying
to talk about some of my deep-seated
[ __ ] in the past I'm like you know what
I got a chip on my shoulder good good
um so I started talking about okay so
why do I need to do that and so I think
what it really
um Harkens back to is my life from when
I was 10 to 15 years old was just a
[ __ ] hell hole I was the only one of
my kindness school I was Tiny I was just
a tiny kid I was the only white kid at
school everyone else spoke Spanish
everyone was so much bigger everyone had
body hair except for me they were a foot
taller than me that explains the beard
now you're just like [ __ ] I'm going
home I'm beating it up man thank God
this is you that's me at 15. bro you're
not a tiny kid at all you're talking but
he's well by the way that's 15 and this
is what I'm getting at and so so what
I'm getting at is
um every day I'm getting the [ __ ] kicked
out of me and I don't fight back not
once you know people are just punching
me and and many times faking ass
whooping well many times I got knocked
out and and the bell had already rung
and I got a fight by bug bag half the
time they hit it most of the time it was
in the trash can I already [ __ ] know
my book bag's gone it's probably in the
trash can and then you got to try and
figure out what period is it what class
am I supposed to be in most of the time
you go to the wrong [ __ ] class
um and that that happened for so many
years that um I remember I would look at
the marinade I had zero self-worth I was
I was totally embarrassed I was
humiliated of like I became this guy and
I wanted to be anything different except
for this [ __ ] guy I did not want to
be this guy
um anyway so I I went through that
probably from about you know 10 to 14 10
to 15. I started I'd been working out
actually for it for a little while
um but probably around 13 14 somebody
said hey man you look pretty strong like
holy [ __ ] really you think I look strong
and so I doubled down on all that stuff
there's a whole lot more to the store I
don't know if you guys want to hear it
but
um we do I actually because I think
they're
you know I do want to hear it and I want
to go through because I think there's a
lot of people that need to hear who are
going through it and it's a very lonely
place and you know when you hear these
stories about why did you become a UFC
fighter I got bullied growing up why did
you become a you know boxer because I
got bullied growing up why'd you go do
bodybuilding because I was sick and
tired of people pushing me around I
wanted to intimidate them through my
muscles why'd you why are you so
relentless and successful because I
couldn't stand being bullied and I
didn't see of somebody of value because
I was always compared to this kid or
that kid that's very natural to go
through that but and by the way again uh
I appreciate you being sincere and being
straight up and and you're not going to
be talking about this a year from now
two years from now five years from now
it's just you do it right now the pain
happens you move on you go to the next
thing and people are going to leave you
alone one thing about the world I've
learned my dad told me something very
interesting when
we saw Kobe the late Kobe and we're Die
Hard Kobe guys and you know we're in La
so that's that's like our guy like
Kobe's my guy a friend a guy that I
really admired watching he's an August
23rd 78 baby I'm in October 1878 baby
when he came to La we grew up with this
guy right so when he went through some
of the stuff
and you saw him fall my dad would say
let me tell you one thing about America
here's what America is all about for
whatever reason Americans fiend seen a
man fall and be publicly humiliated he
says but you know what Americans love
more I said what they love Redemption
they love Redemption stores I just got
the chills all over my body he says they
love Redemption stories he says you may
fall one day don't worry about it they
love redemption in America it's a good
story to be thinking about that because
that is the DNA of America but but I
want to I want to say something because
I I you know I there's some people that
are like well you know why would you
have that guy on let me tell you what
are you doing
why would you do this look I've had I've
had people that have killed people you
haven't killed anybody I've had Mobsters
here I've had criminals here I've had
FBI guys I've had ciagas that are hated
I've had a lot of different people here
okay what you did is you did steroids
and told people you've never done
steroids on PD and GH okay fine no
problem this is the part that I think
I'm going to speak speak on behalf of
the audience and I think this is what
the audience is thinking about and I'd
love to see you address it and we go
from there so you know as a kid
what was most annoying is I'd go to
school I'm a 1.8 GPA guy and I really
I'm like screw all of you guys I failed
biology my teacher Miss Tiffany stood me
and shot up and he says listen even if
you guys get a a hundred on the final
you're not getting a d you can go home
so I'm that guy right
but you know who the annoying person was
in class a person was like oh my God
I got a 98 on the test and I didn't even
study it's so crazy I'm like holy [ __ ] I
must be a dumbass
this person didn't study and got a
freaking a I'm I'm an idiot I'm like
terrible right or or the person like you
know
um oh that girl yeah I got a girl every
day oh these guys everybody wants to be
with me yeah you paid her 500 bucks you
paid the other girl 500 bucks you pay
the attention I must be an idiot I can't
hook up with any girls right and then
the other part all my money it's all
sell you know self-made my parents gave
me nothing 10 years a lady find out the
kid got 28 million dollars when you know
his mom dad or Grandpa died or somebody
that might again don't that's the
feeling that produces frustration
because one cannot compete with that you
know one of the best one of the reasons
why I stopped bodybuilding where it was
gonna be my life and I appreciate the
disguise being straight up with me I get
out of the army I didn't do steroids in
the Army I got out when I got out of the
army I did to six weeks of primobolin I
don't know if you're familiar with Primo
balance you know it's a yeah primobolin
and then I did couple pills of Anadrol
50 and I took some Clan I only took Clen
for one week because Clan made my heart
I'm like dude I can't touch Clint at all
so I this is me at 18 19 years old
that's what I'm going to be doing and
this is pre-premote you know uh I
haven't touched anything here this is
purely in the Army right this is what
I'm going to be doing if you go on the
picture right there on the bottom right
there on the one lower this is if you
click on that that's Primo that's a a
Anadrol 50 that's that face okay I have
21 inch arms at this phase I can't have
21 inch arms naturally uh at 21 years
old uh so now unless if my name is
Ronnie Coleman which he can because he
looked like that until it was 30 years
old
and then one day I went to Mr Olympia
okay and I hung out with all these guys
but put the picture with me and Dorian
Yates top left look this is him and I
when he this is at his Peak when he was
killing everybody and at the bottom 20
some years later we meet each other it's
an interesting picture right so with him
right there yeah that is Venice that's
Venice that a tattoo parlors that's
Advent of speech yeah so we meet the
second time around but I went to Mr
Olympia Vegas never forget because a lot
of [ __ ] happened when I was on Mr
Olympia good bad and ugly all Commander
to my life change at this Mr Olympia
event so and I hung out with all these
guys these are guys that would compete
sixth place fifth place fourth place
their party and heart these guys are
partying like freaking rock stars it was
insane the [ __ ] they were doing stays
between us and them but they were
partying like freaking rock stars and I
said listen guys I want to go into this
space what do I need to do what do you
need to do [ __ ] you really want to go
through it let's go through it
all of this stuff that they went through
and I'm like yeah I'm not gonna do it
and I stepped away and the average
bodybuilder was five Mr Olympia's five
ten is a good height five eight five ten
six two and a half Arnold that's in the
70s you ain't gonna do it today today
you have to be five eight five nine five
ten and I stepped away what I liked
about it was the fact that they managed
expectations with me up front and I made
a decision as a kid when I say kid I'm
21 I'm a grown man but you know it's a
kid compared to these men that are 32 or
34 35 years old you're also 6'4 Pat
despite what the internet says I totally
get it I am 6'4 but what I'm trying to
say is that made me want to say yeah you
look like that because you're using that
I don't have to worry about anything I'm
stepping away that's probably the
biggest challenge I have with this here
is
the fact that it makes a guy sit there
and say
dude maybe I freaking suck so it
actually when you're talking about the
anxiety the four thousand to eighty
thousand people committing suicide the
other day I sent a message a guy texts
me back saying pattern I'm about to kill
myself I'm already talking about to call
this guy like what you're saying is true
it's very very true but I think the
cause of it Brian is
um
there's a guy who's talking to her
talking like so how's your marriage oh
my wife and I never argue I'm like [ __ ]
I'm never getting married because all I
suppose my mom and dad arguing yeah
versus I talk to you on a cow's marriage
what are you talking about 30 minutes
ago we just fought and it was a pretty
bad fight
and marriage is hard and it sucks at
times matter of fact eighty percent time
it sucks because you're dealing with
kids in-laws arguments insecurities your
fears your this finances that are it's
freaking sucks 80 time then I say I'm
willing to get married versus oh we have
a perfect measure I don't want to get
married if you're because I'm never
going to be able to compete with
perfection so I think I think the reason
why people are having so many suicide
and anxiety and panic because they see
so much Perfection with a Kim Kardashian
they see so much Perfection with all
these other people and they say
that I can never amount to this so the
story you're telling now and just
opening up to saying you know I I messed
up royally here's where I'm at uh
believe it or not I'm sure you feel like
you got a thousand pounds off your back
that you're like dude [ __ ] this is
awesome that I don't have to carry this
[ __ ] anymore but also same time I think
if I do maybe I'm alone in this year
maybe I'm just the only one that thinks
like this and fans don't but if I
typically I can understand how the fans
would relate to this I think that's
probably the biggest frustration with
this story because it makes them feel
like when they compare to you maybe
you're just a human specimen and I can
never be like you you know what I'm
saying yeah I think that's the biggest
pain that they're having yeah
you know I love what you said about your
dad
um that advice is incredible
um I love that
um you know as I was growing up my my
dad died before I have a memory of him I
have no memory of him
and uh I didn't have anybody to put
their arm around me you know to Mentor
me and this is not my excuse right but
um but but what I will say is uh I feel
like I've had the opportunity to Mentor
a lot of young men and I feel like when
you say you feel like some weight has
been lifted absolutely I do but for
about one [ __ ] minute because then on
the other shoulder it's like well
there's all this other weight you know
because now I'm going to face everything
that I'm dealing with right now and now
I feel a deeper sense of responsibility
and obligation you know to say we have
to acknowledge that the world is hurting
at record rates and there's this path
forward and it's a simple solution it
doesn't cost anything I understand the
frustration it totally makes sense
um it to me it doesn't change the path
forward it's like we we still nobody's
talking about a lot of these things you
know it's like I want to forcefully talk
about a lot of these things and then I
want to be able to talk about well again
there's modern day primitive culture
tribes live this way early ancestors
live this way you know a lot of people
actually are talking about it like
Andrew huberman Joe Rogan's actually
even talking about a lot of this stuff
they're not calling them the nine and
Central tenants but they're all talking
about sleep they're all talking about
eat they're all talking about they're
all talking about these same things and
so what I'm and they're talking about it
you know in sort of like a disjointed
way you know so what I'm trying to do is
talk about it in a very well organized
packaged way here's what we can do so
that we don't live with depression so
that we don't have suicidal ideation yes
we we have a lot that to measure up to
especially when it's a false expectation
but I believe when you know your roles
and goals in life and I believe when
you're making progress with your roles
and goals in life and I believe that
when you because a lot of people are
like okay like it's this one thing it's
this one thing it's tough to measure up
to the Kim Kardashian it's tough to
measure up to the liver King well it's
so multifactorial you know do you know
how many times somebody's had extreme
anxiety and what they've actually had as
a nutrient deficiency and so many kids
that have been in and out of psychiatric
Wards all they've done is start eating
liver I don't give a [ __ ] who's so if
you're not even buying a supplement they
start eating liver and they've not been
in back into a psychiatric ward and
their anxiety and obsessive compulsive
is gone you know and once again it's not
just how you eat that's how you move
it's getting connection with the sun
it's putting down the damn phone it's
the bond ancestral tenant it's all nine
of these things so there's no doubt what
you said is true um setting an
expectation that that that's impossible
to meet this is unfair right but but
it's so much deeper than that which is
why I'll say you know it's all nine
ancestral tenants once again I I know
this you know I gotta own this and
that's why on the other shoulder I'm
like [ __ ] you know there's even more
weight now now I have to actually like
do a much better job at leading this
charge
yeah I I I I understand I I just want to
make sure that uh you you you see the
pain the fan is going to get if they
think they can never be like these nine
tenants I I agree with every one of them
sleep eat move Shields connect cold Sun
fight Bond you saw what O'Malley said he
says it sucks that this is happening
because this is actually an effective
philosophy like what this is this is
solid you know it the the steroids being
not disclosed no I'm fully natural I'm
this I'm not this unfortunately taints
this a little bit this has a lot of
credibility what you're saying here is
who's debating this there's a bunch of
people that are talking about this but
but I think it's it's just understanding
that
um the fan is sitting there saying I can
never be like this guy I was having a
conversation with my kids I get it I I
was that from 10 11 12 13 14 15. I could
never be like anybody around me I could
never measure up to that so then you
understand the pain that they were this
is what I'm saying like I feel like I
let a whole generation down perfect yeah
liver King how long have you been using
steroids
since I was 40. and how old do you know
44. so for the last four years you've
been using steroids and at age 40 how
massive were you at that point
I probably weighed 180. and you're what
now 195.
all right so you've come clean you feel
good truth shall set you free right
everything that Pat's dad said Gabriel's
signatures right there's wisest man I
know
uh
do you think you'll still continue to
use steroids you know I believe so
deeply in this message that um I'm not
going to do it anymore
but why it feels like and hear me out
you did it you enjoyed doing it clearly
because I mean it made you feel better
it helped you with your self-esteem you
look better you know all the the
positives that came with steroids you've
admitted it
why don't you say yeah I've been using
steroids I'm sorry I lied to you guys
but if you use steroids now you think
that would ruin your entire message why
not just continue if you enjoy it that's
my question yeah well like I said I I
believe so deeply in this message and
that my root cause is really the
overtraining issue I got to figure that
out I got to figure out the over
training issue I gotta figure out the
self-worth issue
um but I do believe I can come off of
steroids
um I'm on testosterone and growth
hormone okay right and I'm on 0.6 CC's I
don't know if you know what that means
not a lot it's it's and so some of the
guys I've talked to they're like
I don't know what that's doing for you
actually
um I have no doubt that the growth
hormone has helped significantly how
addictive are steroids like I have
friends that look they've been partying
they got they got alcohol issues there's
people with you know drug issues pill
popping heroin you hear these crazy
stories about it's hard for me to get
off cigarette smokers all the above are
steroids addictive how addictive are
they I don't know I I've not come off
you know so
um I've not come off of testosterone
it's been a low dose of testosterone for
this amount of time
um I've been on growth hormone for a
year and a couple of months and so you
know in terms of the addiction you know
I don't know
um so what I'm gonna do you know this
whole thing was an experiment you know
to go on it I found a pretty profound
difference in it and so now it's my time
to see okay what the [ __ ] can I do not
taking them at all and hopefully be able
to share that story that doesn't say
that's gonna be a dope Journey just
showing everybody because all the you
know the heart and soil I'm I'm you know
I'm saying I'm a huge fan I use it I
even told Pat earlier I have grass-fed
grass finished Frozen liver I eat that
almost every day just not not too much
but like a couple ounces and just you
know the brain and everything I think
it's gonna be a it'd be a cool
transformation to show everybody and
bring everybody to that Journey because
like Pat said you mess up everybody has
Secrets he has them he has them
everybody in this building has them I
have them some worse than others but
that weight is off and I think you know
taking advantage of this movement now
because those fans that were hurt now
could say Okay manned up and now let's
see where this where this Journey's
gonna go I think I think it's a it's
going to be a good one because I mean
you're still you're still going to keep
working out you're still going to do
everything let me let me let me ask a
question for you Brian so uh uh you've
had money for a minute it's not like you
you didn't fly here on a you know chart
you float here on a private jet you flew
from Austin to New York to here back to
Austin and that that I can tell you the
jet fuel costs what kind of plane is it
that you guys flew in it's citation
Sovereign you spend probably 140 Grand
130 he Grant some number like that and
you know you're spending a six figure
check to just travel New York in here so
a person who does that you're not doing
it if you don't have money so you made
money you've had success with capitalism
and all that other stuff and you've done
well for yourself and your family you
live in a nice place you know you have a
good lifestyle you drive a bigger truck
than mine which is freaking awesome the
F450 it's sick and uh but you know like
uh for myself the first time I was 21
years old I got out of the army so
remember how I said I was going to go be
the Mr Olympia thing and then I met this
guy who introduced me to a billionaire
in Newport Beach
and he started a company and I started
working with this guy uh he was one of
the guys that started shopping.com and
sold it to Alta Vista for 331 he's
living in a 35 million dollar home at
the time 99 his home just sold for 65
million it's the sickest house in
newport's beautiful I wanted to buy it
but I want didn't want to move back to
Newport Beach anyways
um so I started hanging out with this
guy every Sunday I'm entertaining people
on his yacht so I'd go to Balboa Club
whatever it is in Newport I would fill
it up with 60 people and drink champagne
and you know shrimp and hi hey Patrick
but David let me tell you guys a story
about what we got going on here that's
the house that's the founder that's the
this that's that and next thing you know
I'm making money at 21.
and I'm going to Vegas every other
weekend partying my ass off and my ego's
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and you cross the line
from being confident to arrogant to
Untouchable to nobody can tell you [ __ ]
and then boom everything falls and I
lose it all
girl finances debt then the car
everything's gone and I'm by myself and
at this point I'm trying to find the
smallest hole in the wall to go hide it
so nobody can see me and the hole for me
was going back into the army I was going
to escape here to just get the hell away
from everybody I didn't want to deal
with anybody I would go to the clubs and
say hey so where is your car at where
are you with Mr millionaire showing up
on your Ford Focus 228 a month payment I
got from Galpin Ford
um and shout out to Jaime godina for
selling it to me is that I think he's at
Galpin Honda right now he sold my I
bought a bunch of cars from this guy I
love that you're giving him a shout he's
a freaking great sales person great
sales I wish I'm gonna bring him one day
to tell the story when he sold me to car
and how broke I was how many times we
stayed till midnight until I could get
the freaking credit approved to get this
car because my credit score was 500 to
get the sport Focus so pull up to the
car club hey we're the million dollars
at right I'm like oh man I gotta get the
hell out of here I'm so sick and tired
of these [ __ ] questions I'm gonna go
back to the Army
and then the benefit I had I had people
that
sat me down and called my ass out and
let me tell you dude there's nothing
more annoying than that like you want to
slap these people upside the head and
say who the hell are you to talk do you
know who I am
are you sit there and you're taking like
oh
[ __ ] so you then go home and maybe you
don't oh you're out on what on
everything dude everything you thought
you were better than us you thought you
were this you thought you were smart you
thought you know everything you were
doing just pure arrogance that happened
at 21 22. so the best thing that
happened to me is I fell very early then
I realized I need people way ahead of me
in life that as good as I'm doing these
guys are going to make me feel small
there's a there's a power to having
people around you that make you feel
like relax bro you're okay you're not
you're not hot [ __ ] as you think you are
right so do you have those steps of
people in your life that you know when
sometimes you're going through to say
dude listen behind closed doors hey
Brian let's relax this liver King [ __ ] I
get it you're just Brian bro kick it you
know I when I play dominoes which I'll
whoop your ass so you ain't that I know
you know your fears I know you're
insecurities like do you have those
types of people in your life and if you
do who are some of these guys yeah I
have a couple of guys like that um my
wife and I went through a 10-year stint
where we failed over and over and over
it was like we we stuck with something
far longer than we should have and um
and this is my advice to a lot of
entrepreneurs is get in there take
Massive Action you know fail fast fail
early because if you can do that in your
20s I mean what a gift that is
um and I'm like you know what I'm never
going back to that again and when my
wife retired you know she was like Hey
listen I'm gonna go I'm gonna be a
stay-at-home mom and now you're going to
figure all this other stuff out and I'm
like okay cool you know I'm gonna figure
this out and uh and I knew that I would
never go back to a brick and mortar that
was open Monday through Friday from
eight to whatever I'm like okay what's
open 24 7 365. how can I sell on 55
continents 55 continents
55. you're like Elon Musk you go to
other planets yeah
um so I would say that I got a couple of
guys around me that are way smarter than
me that do call me out of my [ __ ] and I
couldn't be more grateful for him you
know what one of them told me a long
time ago
um because we had gone into business
with somebody and
you know before going into business with
somebody like you don't have to ask
anybody anything you just do whatever
you want to do you're the owner right
um and then I went to business with
somebody and I no longer could really
just serve the mission that I had
and I said you know what I'm never doing
that again you know I'm never going to
have a business partner ever again and
then I got to know some guys that were
way better than me that I needed to have
around me so that you know I think
you've heard this before but it's like
you know if if you want to go fast go
alone if you want to go far go together
and you can go fast and far I believe if
you have a true a tribe of True
Believers and so I got a couple of guys
around me that um are way better than me
you know that that do level me up that I
do look to them
um and but but here's the thing that
this this thing I've I've locked this
inside you know I've not shared this you
know with them and um they've had their
suspicions they've asked me in the past
and I've just kind of brushed to the
side and I've always just hey what are
you doing what are you taking look at
the way you look you know and and so
that wasn't fair to them but but I will
say that um there's no way that I would
have any of the success that I've had
financially without this team without
these guys that have been a bit better
it you know we had president Bush at an
event two years ago whatever three years
ago I don't remember it was three years
2019 2019 yeah and when I announced him
people were very upset why would you
bring him here do you understand what
happened with 9 11. I can't believe this
you know we're running an insurance
agency half our Democrats have for
Republicans right so it's not like and
there's a percentage that could give a
[ __ ] about politics but no matter who it
is they don't remember good things about
what media said about President Bush
and he got up and I'm interviewing him
and he starts talking about yeah one day
let me tell you I'm at the house
and I realized for five years my kids
are aging and all I'm doing is drinking
every night when I'm coming home I'm
like what are you doing I took all the
alcohol and I went to the bathroom and I
dropped and so I put it on a flush the
toilet I was like I'm done and then from
there I cleared my life and actually no
Governor president all this stuff you
know at the end of it bro as crazy as it
sounds you know I don't know if history
is going to say this guy's one of the
greatest presidents of all time I don't
know if they're going to say that about
he's one of the greatest of all time but
I do think history is going to say
I like this guy you know I I he's not
going to be on the top 10 list but he's
going to be on the list of what a cool
guy you know he's never trashed Trump
he's never trashed Obama and Obama trash
Trump Obama trashed him Trump trashed
Obama Trump trashed him and he just sat
on the back he's like yeah just been
telling my family so he redeemed himself
and the world is now people who would
never have him on the show they're
having them on their show like I like
this guy so I do think there's a
opportunity we all go through with this
part when you know we sometimes go
through it I just think it's important
to have the right people uh in your life
so by the way
when Adam asked a question I'm looking
for more of them by the way you know
when we're driving over here today I
said you guys strike a rather in the
back seat I said you guys know that we
have the opportunity today to meet
respective Giants in their field the BET
look at what who we met this morning
look at who we're about to meet right
now you better give a firm handshake you
better look them in the eye let's see
your boy I'm telling this to my boys and
I'm saying you realize this is what
you're why you're here you realize what
you're gonna learn it's big when you're
with me yeah and you get to study the
best in the world because of what we get
to do right now you guys pay attention
to this kind of stuff pay attention to
to how pbd asks questions pay attention
to everyone that you're meeting right
now
um and so uh I I guess I'll just say
this is part of my hope and goal right
now is to be able to shake your hand
today and to be able to have you in my
network somebody that I can look up to
somebody that's far better than me
that's achieved so much more than me
that that can make me better I respect
that and bro let me tell you uh for you
know last week Andrew Schultz cornered
me I didn't appreciate it I wanted to
fight him
back we're looking for you Schultz don't
anybody fool you he's a bully come to
Andrew if you're watching this you're a
bully you know who you are so when he's
a bully yeah
is the coolest bully on the campus cool
so you know he Corners me and he's
asking this question do you have any
aspirations politics whatever why not
all this other son I say listen you know
life is very weird you don't know what
role you're playing okay
you may be going through this and you're
training those two boys and one of them
is going to be a president you don't
even know it yet may take you 40 years
to realize holy [ __ ] that's why God put
man how freaking weird is that no and
the issue today in 30 years guess how
big it is like this yeah right it's so
weird how life works I'll take a crazy
story about my dad and then we can
transition into some other things
my dad never talked about his dad I
never met my grandpa my dad's dad always
respect my dad will never say anything
bad about his family
super protect even if they're wrong
he'll never say they were wrong he's
like the straight up like never do
anything to undermine his brothers
sisters none of them even if they
screwed up nothing right
and if he does it's always from a
standpoint up but no one's perfect and
you know he kind of goes that angle so
one day he's like
in the apartment and we're living
together and he's in tears he's crying
and I'm like uh uh so what's what's up
what's going on
because you wouldn't believe what
happened I said what happened and he's
just like rubbing his forehead like this
I'm not we're not living together at
that time I don't know what year this is
but I'm sitting there talking to him
and he says do you know what xiamax just
told me see how Mike is our
brother-in-law we love we call him a
saint he's a sweetheart he married my
sister their 20 year anniversary just
happened a couple weeks ago
he says do you know how my dad died I
said I don't know your dad died my dad
died because he had a stroke
and he says you know it was the most
painful thing for me he says no
I said he says my father in the last
month before he died he said a lot of
painful things to me and he's never said
that to me because I love my dad
and I'm like I have no clue where this
guy's going with this right my get
that's very guarded he won't open up he
says uh
for 35 years since this man died
whatever the time I've been trying to
figure out
why would you on your deathbed say so
like you're such a disappointment son
you're so this these are painful words
from the man you look up to
he says xiamak just came home and told
us his dad just had stroke and he went
to check on his dad and every day his
dad's telling him how disappointed he is
in him okay
and then the doctor after a couple weeks
just supposed to say listen one of the
symptoms when a man's having a stroke
and they're in this situation they say
very hurtful things to the people they
love the most
came to console to my dad and open up to
my dad and my dad's like dude are you
kidding me I've been freaking dealing
with this for 35 years that's what my
dad told me
35 freaking years for my dad to take
this weight off his back it sucks you're
doing someone I just he's telling me the
storm Sinners and holy freak that means
some of the answers to certain questions
that we're going through right now you
mean to tell me I have to wait 35 years
for the answer yes talk about patience
oh my God so you dude you may be going
through the [ __ ] right now and you ain't
gonna know for 30 years and in 30 years
you're gonna be like did you just see
what happened yeah is that yeah damn
Doug like that's the weird thing about
life that when we're going through an
embarrassing moment and it's like all
the spotlights on us you know you ain't
as big of a deal as you think you are
like you know you tell you're saying
relax bro you know you're gonna die
everyone's gonna move on it's going to
be all right but during this time right
now I understand it's painful you know
there's been so many guys that have um
put their arm around me that have been
toward me and there's um one gentleman
in particular who said uh
you know that your kids needed to see
this your kids needed to see you fail
like this your kids need to see how
you're gonna handle this um but he said
hey here's the thing in 20 years they're
going to use all this against you also
and you couldn't talk to me then because
I've dealt with that too yeah you know
and so the the part of what this process
has also revealed to me is like how many
people are putting their arms around me
you know and how bad I've needed people
um a lot of what I do is in this little
bubble and I'm like you know I know I
can do a lot by myself and and man like
there's no way I could have done this by
myself can I ask you one question by the
way this story you just told about your
dad it's so freaking powerful because I
dealt with the exact same thing with my
father and I'm like holy crap and very
powerful
um but back to you Pat asked you a very
I think important question of like
all right you know everyone we all have
to have homies that kind of call you on
your [ __ ] no matter how big you get all
right bro relax all that kind of stuff
like that we all need that my question
is what role was your wife in this
situation because she came in very sweet
lady introduce yourself she says Hi I'm
the liver Queen yeah I go oh Dave
oh dick I'm assuming she must have known
what you were doing
um that's my assumption I'll let you
answer that obviously I'll let me say
two things about that because yeah
earlier when you're like okay who do you
have around you that's better than you
and I don't really want to share
publicly who that is but I'll share
publicly that there's no doubt um that
my wife is number one you know when I
knew her when I first met her I knew she
was way better than me she's still way
better than me
um you know we got this thing in our
household um loyalty above all that
comes from her you know you come home
with a dead body
that person helps you to figure out how
to bury it right and then you talk about
the ethical and moral quandary later and
you deal with that internally
um what I'll tell you is that um I've
never lied to my wife my wife knows
about this
um we're dealing with that internally as
well I don't know if that that partially
answered your question yeah no I mean
just because
to come clean and the whole world and
even your best buddies didn't know about
this but it seems like there was at
least one or
two people that knew the person that
found the emails they knew obviously and
now your wife
so
to be in love with your wife and her and
being your corner I feel like that would
be a double lie in your life so at least
you guys at least had this Bond right
you know like so you're not apologizing
to her that whole thing but now they're
still apologizing to her I mean look at
how I've drugged her into this but she
knew the whole time brother so it's not
like she didn't know so she at any point
should have said Brian
what are we gonna do like it's one of
and like let me just but you did
steroids you didn't rip off a billion
people you're not burning made of you're
not Sam bakeman free like I'm I'm
listening to all this I'm like all right
so Brands and [ __ ] steroids and lied
about it okay so you know the so I like
I'm trying to in the context of the
greater scope of things what Pat is
saying it's not I'm not like what a
scumbag bro I'm just like all right
that's not what it is but at the same
time she was very much in the know
so you know what's your question well he
I was going somewhere with this but you
know just the relationship with your
wife you didn't lie to her about that
right so you're saying that you're
dragging her into it but she kind of
dragged herself into it she knew to me I
just want to protect her I mean I know
that this is my job as a man also right
is to fight to provide and to protect
and and I'll stop at nothing to protect
her and so what what you're saying may
be accurate yeah in my mind this is my
responsibility as a man to always
protect her and so um that's what I'll
say about it but by the way if I if I
may from a different perspective as a
married man uh
you would die to have a wife like that
just just just to just to
you don't know the conversations behind
closed doors that's between him and his
wife that's none of our business that's
between their business uh by the way
that's not the English I know you're not
all I'm I just want to come to the
audience that gets the context as well
dude Michael went to jail Francis went
to jail for God knows how many years and
he was been with his wife for 39 years I
don't know they just celebrate 38 holy
[ __ ] can you imagine you go so there's a
people like that you see and you just
have to say
man do you have a sister like it's one
of those types of things that can you
introduce me to your sister or a cousin
that has your genes and DNA because it's
hard to find yeah that level of loyalty
to be clear the question I was asking is
at least you weren't lying to her this
whole time that'd be a different
situation it's like not only am I lying
to the public and my kids and my friends
and my family it's I'm also lying to the
person that I sleep with next every day
that's a different type of regret that
you would have that's what I'm doing
listen a friend a friend of mine went on
if there's one person that knows you're
on stuff is your wife you know why and
again I'm not getting into the personal
stuff because when you are you have to
go two or three times a day okay so if
your wife is interesting we're not going
once every other day every three days
[ __ ] this guy wants me to go towards the
time I'm freaking tired I got to work
out to be able to handle you [ __ ] it's
like
testosterone level from 400 to 12 1400
dude she may be running away is that
true Brian I'm not telling he doesn't
have to disclose that but hit that smile
on his face says a lot of stories go
ahead man surprise because your wife
Barbara
discover that that's what a juicy
Barbara your wife she's you know she's
you know seems amazing you know I follow
her on on Instagram how do you think how
was she how was she what's the backlash
story because I'm pretty sure because I
know people are in [ __ ] talkers and
how's she doing with them I'm pretty
sure people are hitting her up and like
I can't believe your husband like how
how is how is she going through and how
is it affecting her you know I don't
know she's uh she says it all in her
eyes yeah you know I mean the way that
she looks at me the support that she
gives me in her eyes you know like um
the way she puts her arm around me the
affection that she shows me the physical
love that she shows to me
um you know we have just uh such a
healthy perspective on hate you know
what we've always said and what we teach
our kids and my wife and I this is all
like our principles our philosophies
that govern all of these actions right
is that
um when you when you hear a word
like these are just vibrations that
enter your ear and it's up to your brain
to assign meaning to it right and so if
you hear hate if you read hate it's the
same thing it's your brain that assigns
meaning to it and so the meaning that we
automatically assign is these people are
suffering and struggling and hurting and
hating the most the language that they
speak in is hate so we got to do our
jobs you know even more now it's like
it's so like if we read hate it's like
it's not like we perceive it as
something negative it's like okay we got
a job to do look look at how badly
people are hurting and so um I don't
know my my wife is uh I think we're both
very similar like with these attitudes
it's like it's a silver linings kind of
attitude did you get that from The Four
Agreements by the way no never read that
no where they say don't take anything
personally yeah just a reflection of
what so many people are thinking when
somebody's [ __ ] crap and they're just
going at you it's almost like you have
to stop and tell yourself like wow
what's really going on with that person
you know what they're built up so much
when I started my first company that
every email was like this you know and
it was like holy [ __ ] you know like you
just have to realize how bad they're
suffering and and if you understand how
bad they're suffering you can help them
right because I mean you know like the
natural inclinations okay am I going to
fight back you know they were coming to
you because they were suffering with
something in the in the first place you
have an opportunity to guide them to a
better life everything that we say to
each other is a metaphor for something
right the only way that metaphor makes
sense is when we process it and assign
meaning to it and if you always give you
know the illusion of hate the benefit of
the doubt it's like you know I spoke in
the hate language you know like after 10
11 12 13 I started to keep a list of
people that if I could get a gun these
these guys wouldn't exist anymore and so
um I know how to speak and I know what
that means you know I know where it's
coming from it's coming from a place of
deep [ __ ] hurt and so the second that
either of us see that you know it's like
well you know we feel pretty decent
about ourselves like we we know they're
not actually trying to attack us what
they're really doing is they're speaking
their own language and and we need to
help them I would just say my wife has
just been she celebrated her 50th
birthday a couple days ago oh happy
birthday and and we're having this um
this dinner she's she's 50. yeah your
wife that just walked in his 50th yeah
this is 50. she looks fantastic wow
she's 49 right there oh great respect
and and here's the thing we're going
around the table and um we're sharing
wins uh just you know one of one of the
great things that happened previously uh
on that day and and so then I looked
over at her it's my turn and I'm like
you know uh I just got really choked up
and all I could really say was I love
you but it's because of the way that she
spent you know that this last week like
because of how badly I needed her and I
never said hey I need you you know but
like she knows and and uh and what she's
given me the strength and the support
that she's given me you know to to face
this and to do this you know it's
there's no way I could do this without
her that's awesome how long you guys
been together 18 years respect uh but by
the way you know uh uh
um
one of the things that I love a topic
that's doing very well right now A lot
of people are talking about this topic
is you know uh being stronger man and
you know all this you know uh uh what
still toxic masculinity I actually think
it's great the fact that this topic is
is out there and the it's getting men to
realize hey I gotta stop being a pansy
and I gotta stop I just got a call today
on the way here from Robert Kiyosaki and
we're talking about the most interesting
topic he called me to just tell me hey
someone tell you man I I watch this and
I want to remind you the role that we
played and we always joke about being a
wartime leader during covet him and I
would talk all the time but you know
talk about how at least for you what was
it like you know the the consequences of
a missing father figure you're like I
don't even know what it is to be raised
with a father figure sometimes we don't
talk about that enough we talk about let
me tell you what that kid did let me
well let me tell you the role of a
father plays in a man's life and what it
looks like if he's not there yeah so
what were some of the things like you
know where you're like I can home one
day and I needed to talk a man talk to a
man not my mom a man wasn't there I came
home with what were some of those events
during that time that impacted your life
now this is like a Tarantino movie what
I was saying earlier my 10 to 15 year
old days where I just got pushed and
beat up and I never stood up for myself
um there's this new kid Chuck who came
to school another white kid like me I'm
like I'm gonna make friends with this
guy
um but from day one he was getting in
fights but he was fighting back and
blood was everywhere you know I'm like
[ __ ] you know like maybe I could still
make and I made friends with him
and then and then when they knew that he
was going to fight back he made friends
with them
and so I no longer had a friend and they
said something they said something about
me that he no longer wanted to be my
friend so he comes out into the
courtyard and he starts pushing me and
pushing me and I'm walking back and I'm
walking back and now there's 30 people
there's a big [ __ ] crowd yeah
um anyways I tripped over a planter and
I fell on my ass and I said you don't
want to fight me I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know and I believe that
um and here's the thing you know like
again I so I go home and I do the same
thing I'm like you know I wish I had
somebody to talk to about this you know
and but it was the same conversation I
had with myself in the mirror like
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you're
worthless you know what are you gonna do
to change your life
um this big thing happened that changed
my life not too long after that
um this kid Chris Rivera wanted to pick
a fight with me if he got in this fight
he would join this gang and so they tell
me hey there's this fight that you need
to be in and uh and when I say they tell
me my brother I have an older brother
um and uh and his friend Justin and
Justin's mom was around and they said
you need to be in this fight and I'm
like what I've never been in a fight
I've never thrown a punch back I wish I
had the dad that said Hey listen it
doesn't matter if you get your the [ __ ]
handed to you you need to stand up for
yourself you need to fight you need to
do this thing for yourself but nobody
told me that um and you know I think
this might be one of the greatest things
that happened to me at this stage of my
life I believe this is my first true
rite of passage what ends up happening
is um Justin's mom says you need to
fight because you're strong
and then Justin said that too and my
brother said that I'm like what the [ __ ]
are you talking do you even know who I
am do you know you know what I'm
thinking anyways they convinced me to do
it she drove me to the fight oh wow she
drove me to the fire your friend's mom
in the van oh Sam in the van and uh and
and speaking of gangster I mean this his
gang was behind him he's standing there
and I get out of the van my heart's
going a mile a minute I kind of walk up
quickly he's waiting there for me he
starts approaching me I'm facing him and
um and I threw a punch from like a mile
away everything that I had a maker I had
no idea what was going on
um I threw myself to the ground you know
I wish I could see this today
oh my God if you if you could see this
again I I know it came from a mile away
yeah I know I gave it every [ __ ]
thing that I had you know and so I threw
myself on the on the ground so hard I
could have knocked myself out probably
God that's hilarious and this guy Chris
comes up to to kick me because I'm on
the ground and um I was able to catch
his foot I was able to get a hold of his
legs I was able to feel how strong I was
and I manhandled them that's awesome and
I put him on the ground and I manhandled
him so effortlessly that I pinned both
of his elbows to the ground underneath
my knees I had this hand on the neck I
don't know if you've seen this [ __ ] in
the movie but it's like all from the
[ __ ] movie yeah and so I'm getting
ready to do my thing and I looked in his
eyes and I saw this pathetic scared as
[ __ ] hopeless helpless kid
and uh and so I saw me
and I couldn't do it there's no [ __ ]
way I could do it and um just the other
day I'm I'm in the car driving to go say
my apology uh video and I'm telling
myself this story why why why why why do
you have to over trade like what what
are you dealing with and I'm telling the
story and I'm getting choked up and I'm
like holy [ __ ] like I'm able to go deep
on this I I know I can talk about this I
know that this is you know a big big
part of that issue
um and I couldn't do it and I got up and
uh and he didn't there was no
retaliation whatsoever there was a
mutual understanding here
um there was a mutual understanding
between us the gangs throwing rocks and
cracks or mini cracks the window on the
minivan we get back inside she says I'm
proud of you Justin says I'm proud of
you my brother says that I'm proud of
you you're strong and
um you know what I knew right then is
like as worthless as I had felt up to
that point I can do that and if I can do
that what else am I capable of and I
knew that it had been my working out
that had led me to that and now I
finally got the first time first chance
in my life to feel what that felt like
to actually be strong to have some sense
of [ __ ] control
thank God you know that this happened
um but I will say this this started this
maniacal drive to be in the gym to do
this to double down it's like
um I I know what my roles and goals are
in life like I only pick a few of them
because I know I can only be great at a
few things I'm not a good son I'm not a
good brother I'm not even a good friend
it's like you know what I'm I'm good to
myself to express my highest and most
dominant form like as a man I know I'm a
good husband I know I'm a good father I
dedicate everything to that there's
there's these other things these other
roles that are important to me that are
probably the worst in the world that but
this is what I knew like there's this
maniacal Drive the ability to have some
sense of control some strength so
um I don't even know how this whole
thing started but this this is this is
why I started telling the story man it's
because uh thank God that happened I was
about the father figure and the
mentoring because I because he wasn't
there but she stepped in Justin's mom
stepped in she told me to do this this
was the equivalent of what a dad should
do wow you know and so the thank God I
did that shout out to the mom wow
wherever she is if she's around that's a
people are you still you still can keep
in contact with them or not oh no you
know I mean this is in Middle School
um there are no cell phones or anything
you know cell phones didn't come out
till I was after college but um but but
here's the thing uh
this guy and his mom were uh involved
with some really illegal [ __ ] and and my
mom said there ain't no [ __ ] way
you're gonna go to the high school that
this middle school feeds to by the way I
want to point this out in eighth grade I
almost figured out how to fit in now I
got my ears pierced I'm stick back I'm
now I finally have some hand-me-downs
from one of my mom's boyfriends where
I'm kind of figuring this out that my
mom says you ain't gonna be friends with
this guy anymore we're moving over here
and it doesn't even matter if we have
the same phone number would she change
the number anyways like we there's no
more connection and and this was one guy
that I had started to gain respect from
and I couldn't believe she was going to
take my friend away I just figured out
how to kind of fit in she moves me to an
all-caucasian school there now I don't
look like anybody again because now I
got my hair sticked back I'm wearing
baggy pants everybody has short hair
everybody's an athlete everyone's
wearing these uh like kicker you know
tight jeans yeah boots I gotta do it all
over again you know and what once again
like these are all gifts you know like I
went through that and a big part of um
when I try and you know challenge myself
to figure out with my own boys is how do
I put these kind of challenges not no I
would never wish this upon anybody what
I went through but I know I got to make
life hard for them and so I got to
figure out you know well how do I do
that and not burn a bridge how do we not
not not go too far
um so I I would say like that that's
probably just a classic opportunity you
know like she was like my dad and she
mentored me and I think she changed the
trajectory of my life in that minute by
the way did you ever were you ever in
the military or no no you've never been
a military okay yeah you you look you
talk like a guy that was you talk like a
guy that either had a very strong male
uh example in your life or you were in
the military where you were around
others my dad was in them everybody was
in the military yeah except I was
supposed to go into the military I mean
absolutely everybody you know I was
raised on bases I was born and say about
Puerto Rico on a base I mean it's
nothing but bases so um I don't know
maybe that has something to do with it
with the military site yeah yeah that's
cool why didn't you join if everybody
else was in the military my mom chose my
curriculum for me and uh and so she had
me study biochemistry and uh things to
to become a doctor you know anyways um
at one point I'm like I figured out my
mom chose
almost everything for me and I'm like
why am I doing this I had no idea I said
I'm not gonna go do that there's not a
whole lot of things you can do with that
degree also so I went to go work for a
pharmaceutical company for a while and
so anyways um I but but I after seeing
Top Gun I was like oh that's what I'm
gonna do and when I would go train I
would go and I would train and I would
just replay or I'm gonna drive that
motorcycle I'm Gonna Fly that jet you
know but uh yeah I took a different path
late in the game
and where's your brother these days so
because how many years old is he than
you he's about a year and a half so
throughout all this I mean it sounds
like that would have been a perfect
scenario for him to be like the Big
Brother Big Mentor but it sounds like he
wasn't involved whatsoever so what was
that yeah I just said my brother got
mixed up in drugs got him I'm sorry
pretty pretty
bad deeply yeah got it listen the one
thing about about life man you know when
I learned this as as you age you try to
be like well you know everybody has to
act like uh how perfect everyone's
family is and then right around the 30
number you realize yeah everyone's
family's got some problems everyone's
got some screwed up things in their
story some it's parents some with
siblings some it's
but you know grandparents it doesn't
matter everybody's got some issues by
the way just out of curiosity so for you
when it what what do you think of like
uh uh if if somebody you know like the
stories you read about uh there's this
one book called the Ageless man I don't
know if you've read the book ageless man
yeah where the guy says you're you're
you're not healthier if you're stero if
your testosterone level is lower you
need to be like nowadays A lot of people
aren't trt more than people would know
there's a lot of people that are in the
NBA that are using stuff there's a lot
of guys that are in the NFL using stuff
there's a lot of people that are in
politics content creators a lot of
people Hollywood movie stars you saw Joe
Rogan calling out The Rock The Rock
needs to come out and do what you know
him did how many people you think are on
stuff that we don't know about oh I have
no idea you know I mean I I don't know
you know I tell my kids this all the
time you know and if I say this to
anyone who engages with me like don't
compare yourself to me don't compare
yourself to anybody right I mean one of
the most famous lines I say non-stop is
to express your highest the most
dominant form right compare yourself to
yourself right because obviously once
you start doing this like well how the
[ __ ] are you ever going to measure right
you're never going to measure right so
do these things these are the ways of
our early ancestors this is how we honor
the struggle of our early ancestors this
is how you can express your highest and
most dominant form I have no idea you
know like who's on just trt or I mean I
guess we would have an idea of who's on
more than trt you know but um but uh
this is not a conversation that I
generally have yeah because I mean trt I
watched like from Facebook and
everything trt there there's it's it's
they're promoting it everywhere you know
I mean on Facebook you I I I get all
that where you go get the test and they
they'll they'll tell you where your
testosterone is at and they'll send it
literally to your door it's not illegal
right trt correct yeah it's not it's not
like a trt is not the big deal so what
up my question because I really don't
know is the growth the thing that people
are saying that that's a steroid I mean
it's not like anabolic like um like Deca
or all that other stuff I mean what's I
don't see like the big problem with it I
think you could categorize it it's a
poor performance enhancing drug yeah you
know technically it's not a steroid
hormone it's a peptide hormone but
there's no doubt that it's helped with
performance and Recovery there's no
doubt you know I had a close friend say
hey you should not say you're taking
steroids you should tell people what
you're taking which is testosterone and
growth hormone yeah and I'm like you
know what what I've done is I've
undershared let me over share it please
yeah I'm taking steroids yeah I've been
on steroids I'm on steroids you know
right now which is testosterone and
growth hormone I would say growth
hormone has played a significant role
you know and help it be to recover to
help me get in the gym as many times as
I want I do think it has made a big
difference but at 100 percent is through
a clinician through a trained
professional monitored and managed and
everything is written as a perception so
and I'm probably like just I mean
health-wise and I'm happy that you're
doing it the right way and doing all
that like health-wise for future stuff
are you worried because I mean there's
only so much the heart and the body can
actually take no matter what a doctor
says do you have any worries about that
ever like catching up or like a heart
attack or something crazy you know what
I did and um you know early on I also
was on Deca and Winstrol and so my blood
chemistry was all [ __ ] yeah it was all
was all deranged
um and I'm like you know I'm here to be
a dad I'm here to be a husband like I
don't I if if this is gonna [ __ ] this up
I'm gonna get off this uh and so that
was pretty clear I mean we we
discontinued um the DECA and the
winstrong and the blood chemistries look
good perfect yeah it's great
um so I mean again like I think it's
very nuanced who should even consider
this right for a young man don't don't
even think about it I mean there's no
steroid there's no form of any steroid
that's appropriate for a 15 year old or
a young man or even 18 or because I mean
your body's producing it you're just
you're just throwing money down the
toilet your body's you're in Prime
testosterone you're awesome exactly yeah
but there is there is one thing that you
know that I uh uh I'm sure you're
already planning for this when Adam
asked you know you're going to continue
like I made a decision I'm going to get
off of it
four years you know of being testing
with these different things to get off
you're gonna need to get off with
somebody that's watching and monitoring
because you like you said I don't know
the side effects I've only been doing it
for 40s that was a perfect answer it's
like I've been doing it for four years
yeah and
it's not easy to get off of stuff you
know it's a it's a challenge and it's
best to have somebody very close that's
telling you what to do when you are
getting off of this stuff I got a
brilliant friend who knows a lot about
this where do you live you live in
Austin right you're in Austin or I'm
between Houston and Dallas but okay got
it um I I just also want to say this is
my plan to do that
this might not work out but this is my
plan to do this and I believe meaning
get on off of it may not work out yeah
it might not work out meaning you may
get back on it you know what again
that's not my intention but like let's
say it's been three or four months let's
say that I
I have no cognitive ability my physical
bit you know like I've just the wheel
you're gonna feel it bro I've been
reading I've been reading and I'm like
oh my God like this is this is are you
are you in contact with any major
bodybuilders or no no okay are you open
to the idea of to talking to somebody
absolutely okay would you mind if I put
you in contact with it I would
appreciate it yeah I will because they
can tell you stuff I can't and I'm going
to put you in contact with like the main
guys
that they'll talk to you about this
because I would not suddenly there's
certain things you can do cold turkey I
I don't know if it's that healthy you
got to tell you something funny so this
morning uh I don't know if it was Andrew
Schultz or one of the his co-hosts yeah
when's the last time you did steroids
and I saw I had a shot on Saturday I go
oh [ __ ] you know what actually today I
had I did growth I did growth hormones
every day I had a growth hormone today
and and this is the thing like I know
that you can't just come off with a cold
turkey you know I know that there's a
plan there's a way to do it an
intelligent way to do it I also know
it's going to be what I've read it's
really hard to do and I'm sure there's
best practices you know to transition to
at least lessen that but but what I'm
really hoping to do is like I'm gonna
give that everything I'm gonna give that
a shot yeah just just just be before you
because okay so right now there's
there's a few things that is going on
that you're you're going through your
you're going through something that
you've never gone through before which
is what public apology let me go talk to
a few of the guys that I respect and
they're they're going to be able to do
this in a respectful manner just make
sure you're not making commitments
that's going to be very hard to and
don't say publicly because there's he
did it again he did again so it's just
like like what you just said I don't
know I don't know what's going to happen
all I'm saying is if you're
you want to get off of weed you know how
they say like you gotta when you're
dropping a bad habit you got to replace
with something else okay there's a big
difference of getting off of steroids
and stop drinking alcohol or stop
smoking weed you get off of weed okay
maybe you're gonna chew or smoke cigars
or something that you're replacing it
with the original replacing growth
hormone and steroids with something else
that's gonna fill the need in your body
that's not because
wheat is not dramatically you know or
this is my you get what I'm saying maybe
I'm wrong about this but I'm convinced
that it's my obsession with over
training that's that's screwing up my
hormones you know that that I think that
if if I can fix a way and find a way to
not have to do this two or three times a
day and just do it at least once a day I
think if I do it once a day get into the
gym at least once a day and not do two
or three times a day
um I think because over training clearly
has an effect on your hormone profile
and again I know that there's a whole
other thing to consider about I'm not
producing any of my natural stuff right
now you know there's a negative feedback
going on how am I going to get my own
natural stuff going on but but then it's
really addressing the root cause and I
believe the root the root cause well the
root cause is really these self-worth
things that I got to deal with and I got
to go deep with but then I also got to
say listen I'm not going to go into the
gym two or three times a day you know I
know that I got to figure out a way to
sleep I know that I got to figure out a
way to recover I know that I got to
figure out a lot of this stuff any
connections with anybody who has
experience with it oh dude I want to
give you the right people and you talk
to them and my recommendation is to be
very methodical with the right support
before you go through this transition
bro I'm just telling you it's I saw one
guy go through it you want to talk about
like like uh hardcore anxiety like
emotional breakdown depression it's not
it's it's a serious thing so this is not
something you go sudden cold turkey and
there are certain things you you've
you've read about all this stuff how to
naturally increase your testosterone
level deadlift squats all this stuff
there's certain things you eat too
naturally also but you're going to go
through it you're going to go through it
it's it's a it's a thing but with the
right support and the right counsel
you're going to go through it's going to
be fine you know what I'm saying so
um yeah Brian I just kind of want to
lighten the mood for a sec it's kind of
cold in here by the way it's freezing
how often it's gonna be wearing a
sweater I'm wearing sweaters my nipples
meanwhile you're out here chest out abs
are you not chilly what's about him you
know how are you sweating right now I've
always been like this I've always you
know like I've always been like this in
my 20s and my 30s I don't know what it
is you know but uh the the benefit is
when it's really cold outside I usually
do pretty good I'm chilling but any
other time you know like I asked my guys
hey is there any way you can get in
touch with it is there any way you can
ask him to lower the AC just a little
bit we did we're all paying the price by
the way when's the last time you were
sure I was just gonna ask that yeah like
like somebody's like behind wedding are
you just like I'll wear a bow tie I'm
not wearing no sure you know normally
it's just um really sorry can't come to
your wedding oh really you know because
they're like brother you know I I
haven't had to figure that out yet um I
don't wear shirt very often I got yeah
you know and and by the way this was a
thing way before social media I didn't
wear a shirt yeah and and so a lot of
people say hey why don't you wear a
shirt there's a lot of reasons why I
don't wear a shirt you know I mean part
of it is when I explain you know the
Primal raw first version himself you're
undomesticated self you know show me how
you look bare chested you know reveal to
me you want to go right now brother
your philosophies your principles let's
have a conversation you know obviously
how we look bare chest it doesn't say
everything about us but it says
something right about us and I didn't
wear a shirt before social and so I
decided I'm not putting on a shirt after
social you know a lot of people actually
through all this stuff happening
um try to say hey here's what here's how
you should say your apology and you
should put a shirt on nah you're like no
one I'll do the apology bro there's no
shirt that's coming on here so Brian how
hard is this like going out or like
going to like a restaurant or something
like do you deal with that or do they
recognize you and they're like yo it's a
liver King you know a goddamn table no I
assume you put a shirt on when you go to
a restaurant it's pretty nice I don't he
doesn't he says he's in Texas Texas
we make a video of it and there's like a
five-star restaurant people are wearing
suits and ties it's all nice and and you
have me dropping down at the dinner
table doing Max effort push-ups my
simulated hunt before I eat look looking
like a caveman I love it you know and
and so then we we make a small video out
of it and and so thank God you know I
have a great team that calls ahead of
time and says hey here's what's going to
happen you know if there's if there's
not a private room you know yeah they
disagree where did this whole mindset
these nine tenants like what what what's
the inspiration behind all of this yeah
um I think I alluded to this earlier my
real why in the world is my kids
couldn't breathe they were allergic to
everything dust dogs food you name it
um they would go into this anaphylactic
shock they couldn't breathe
um they were taking ambulance trips to
the hospital we had to use epipens
doctors kept giving the same [ __ ] to
lose both of them both of them and where
were you living when this was happening
same place you are right now no not not
same place in the city we're living in
the city okay um yeah right in the
middle of the city and um it was more
EpiPen more Benadryl more allergy shots
same thing kept happening and what we
realized is you know we have the extreme
issues where they would have to go to
the hospital but if you really paid
attention they hardly ever could just
take a deep breath they were always
having issues breathing they always had
these bags around their eyes you don't
really notice it because this is your
everyday right and um you know one day
I'm like you know what enough is enough
I'm not giving that to them anymore you
couldn't go anywhere I mean they were
allergic to our own dog they might go to
a friend's house and you gotta have like
your whole rescue kit emergency plan
exit strategy you got to tell everybody
around here's what here's what you got
to do I'm like man you can't raise your
kids like that like this is your job as
a dad to figure this out and so with
enough research I Came Upon This like
ancestral living principle that these
forces that enabled us to be healthy
these robust strong healthy individuals
since the beginning of time maybe we
still need these things right which our
sleep eat moves you'll connect cold Sun
fight and bond but primarily I said you
know what let's start with eat what if
what we're feeding them what if what I'm
feeding them is creating these issues
and so we just got rid of all the
processed foods it was like overnight
liver Queen did it she threw away I
couldn't believe it either because I
like to eat a lot of ice cream you know
I mean at the time I was like I would do
a whole container you know and I and I
couldn't believe it I'm like well hold
on you know time out time out I'm never
gonna do that again and so she got rid
of absolutely everything and so through
that transition you know like she would
put chiefly liver and bone marrow and
egg yolks in front of them do you think
they want to eat that of course not it's
because you're Raw forget it they
wouldn't touch it they wouldn't touch it
and she would make bone soups they
wouldn't touch it after three or four
days of not eating you know they started
eating it they were hungry and then they
wanted more of it and then immediately
like we saw the lights come on and we
saw this personality this vibrancy that
we had never seen before and then it's
like how dulled down were they and we
didn't know this until going through
this process I'm like holy [ __ ] you know
maybe this eat ancestrally works and so
um I had read this in a book and uh
Sally Fallon's nourishing Traditions
there's a couple of other books that
that we had read at that time but that
was a landmark book for us and then we
started to think okay from first
principle thinking what else are we
missing you know like our kids are going
from the house to a car to another
building right and they're not getting
outside and when they're outside we're
putting sunblock on them how much sun
are they getting did we evolve with sun
you know there's so many of these things
you know first principle thing I'm like
okay what did we get right what did we
get wrong how can we expand upon this
and um until we started to go and visit
with with these tribes in the Amazon in
Africa and in Mongolia to study their
ways to see if we can validate the nine
ancestral tenants maybe expand upon the
nine ancestral tenants so when we figure
this out for our kids you know I thought
okay like what kind of piece of [ __ ]
doesn't share this with the world yeah
so that that's what I'm like okay this
is what we're gonna do from now on every
company is going to be about teaching
the nine ancestral tenants and so um
really it just took off they killed all
the grass-fed grass finish from the bone
marrow to the side I do all of it I get
all Frozen and Chip you get it from him
the heart and soil 100 that's what I'm
gonna talk about sponsors oh you get all
this I I 100 we're living in the like
the like you said grass-fed the bone
marrow I haven't I've tried the raw but
it's not I I you know just by itself I
put on top of the steak I eat you know
raw you know raw honey the cheese fruits
vegetables I'm sorry barely an adventure
are you a vegetable
you like vegetables get down here you
could get down them but the bread is
gone I I and I'm telling you right now
mind bought everything else is a
completely different attitude now when I
I eat like [ __ ] even a little bit I feel
it like I want to pass out if I eat like
red and glue and I'm I and I'm dead
serious after lunch with that I want to
take a nap so it's 100 I mean like I
said the Sean O'Malley said the same
thing that people might be like oh well
how could you believe now that [ __ ]
works it really really works getting the
Sun and getting the right food in you
night and day you know there's just
maybe hundreds of thousands of anecdotes
about this I mean if if you just go on
Amazon and look at some reviews about
people that have turned to this
lifestyle you know again I just want to
like remind everybody that most people
go to a job they hate they come home to
a life that that they don't love they
sedate themselves and distract
themselves to call it a day to call it a
week call you know it's like
um there's a better life to live and
most of these things are free to do
eight of them are are free to do
accessible to everybody and and even the
food aspect of this I think it's a wash
you know or you can possibly save money
on food nobody says you got to get a
stick you can go get you know ground
beef yeah when I started this the organs
cost like two dollars but most butchers
were given the organs 100 100 yeah we're
giving the organs away um and so I mean
now now the organs actually they're
expensive there's more money
um but but that's how the whole thing
started and you know there's there's a
lot of vegans and vegetarians that come
they're like hey I think a lot of what
you're saying is cool but this whole
other thing I got a problem with I'm
like cool you know what there's eight
other ancestral tenants for you right
focus on those other rate and if those
other eight don't get you leading a
better Kick-Ass life then you can talk
about just introducing liver you know if
that doesn't get you better just think
about that and one other thing I want to
point out you know my takeaway when
um by the way Joe Rogan you know and
Derek talked about me for like 30
minutes and someone said how did you
feel about them like man I couldn't
believe they talked about me for 30
minutes and and at the end what Joe
Rogan said is that liver is great that
he eats it all the time and then Derek
said Heats it every day yep you know
liver is king is not about my name is
liver Kings this is not about calling
myself a king this is about if I can say
liver King three times in a one minute
clip on Instagram what you're always
going to hear is the name is liver King
because liver is King these guys are
saying liver is King you know my
takeaway from that 30-minute assessment
was like thank God they promoted liver
you know thank God that they did that
because that's such a low love lover for
so many people to do when you start
eating liver most people feel more
energy energy more drive more
determination their mood's getting
better and then then I'm hoping that
they're thinking okay what else is this
guy talking about now if you get early
morning sun now most people don't know
that early morning sun sets your whole
circadian rhythm you know and then
connecting I mean there's so many of
these things that are free easy
accessible to do and will make such a
massive difference specifically liver
though I that's what you're saying we're
all liver not meat not protein
specifically liver is that what you're
saying let me share a little bit about
that with you when you go and you visit
with the Hudson or any of these
permanent culture tribes they don't even
eat the muscle meat they go for the
liver first they go for the organs and
and first I read this in in one of these
books and uh I forget which book it was
actually but I read it in a book and I'm
like really do they do that and then
when you actually see them throw the
muscle meat to the dogs and give it to
the birds it's like holy [ __ ] this is
actually true yeah they eat the organs
and they start with the liver and bone
marrow usually you know animals in the
wild do the same thing you know it's
enough to watch that on on a documentary
I'm like okay that's cool right I can
say that as much as I want but I gotta
go see this now what about chop liver
what about it in Judaism all the Jews
they got the chopped liver you know what
am I chop level that whole thing is
chopped liver in that in in your diet
any kind of liver straight up yeah and a
shout out to all the Jews out there you
chopped liver you just made his day I
just made my day
that's a compliment good good well it
does but it does lose its uh it does
lose its like it's pure obviously when
you cook it because eating it raw I'm
not gonna front I put a little uh light
soy sauce with some uh sesame oil I put
some green onion I just I don't really I
chop it up I dice I swallow every day I
put a little maple syrup on my little
maple syrup oh really salty you ate
liver every day every single day I I
bought it online I chop it up because
it's frozen it I thought I put in those
little freezers Ziploc bags and if you
go in my freezer I have right now I have
a hundred little Frozen pieces I defrost
it Brian I defrost it chop it up I do my
dick Patrick I'm telling you right now
it's the energy wow and so I swear and
people in the office like yo it's Vinnie
on cocaine I'm like no I'm on liver we
got the liver kids
here right now I'm on liver bro and then
like in the morning it's funny somebody
today Rob when you pulled up today what
was I doing you're standing out and
getting sunlight come on bro I was like
this
I had no idea who you really was a
person I know you're going through River
bro and I really hope I think obviously
what Pat said it's gonna it's gonna
change people change their minds but all
around you're a good dude I see like the
the past of the no father and the story
and who you are and how you're going to
be with your with your sons and I think
I think God I'm a Christian I'm not an
overly religious guy everything happens
because it's a it's a plan and you're
going through it right now you're going
to be fine I really do I really do
believe it 100 thank you so you when it
when it comes down to you were saying we
were living the city at the time before
we left the city what city was it when
you were talking about your kids your
boys Houston oh you were living in
Houston got it yeah I have a hard time
with San Antonio you know Charles
Barkley has a hard time with sending 24
different reasons I grew up in San
Antonio did you really yeah I went to
San Antonio every time I went to San
Antonio I would end up in the emergency
room fighting and finally I'm like what
the hell is going on with San Antonio
finally one day I go and I'm like dude
what is wrong with the city so my CFO is
from San Antonio and my CEO is from San
Antonio are you kidding and everybody I
have around me is from San Antonio
apparently San Antonio has one of the
highest uh pollen counts in America
because there's this tree that the wind
comes that produces unbelievable amounts
of pollen that comes in so if you're at
all allergic let's just say if you are I
never knew I was allergic until I'm 38
years old I go to San Antonio having
these issues but that's why I thought
maybe you were talking about San Antonio
because San Antonio and I don't get
along yeah different reasons against for
Barclay but yeah I can't get along
Remember the Alamo station I was in the
United States Air Force well I was at
San Antonio Lachlan Air Force base and
I'm allergic to what you were talking
about and then about the heat people
don't realize what real heat is when
it's black flag on the base you're
standing at attention people just drop
Levine for for for people who lived in
Iran yeah
a few years ago and all of a sudden news
comes out record-breaking day in Dubai
128 degrees we were in Dubai that day
but you know a city in Iran was 150
something on that it was a
record-breaking on the paper ever if you
pull up the day it'll tell you exactly
when we were in Dubai let me guess the
date it's got to be July of 20 20
2015. what's the date
yes the Record highest record-breaking
day on paper what day does it say July
2019 no the one we won was in 2015 uh
hottest day it was a city in Iran
anyways so you really are not lying when
you say this because when I moved to
Dallas for the year when we started the
podcast and everything it was it was
pretty right there there you go July
31st 2015 how to stay on record 165
degrees you could cook I said 150 165 we
weren't we were in a Dubai insane
thought it was and when before we moved
to Florida because I'm born and raised
in Miami and Pat's Iran La Dallas he's
like so give me the the pros and cons of
living in in South Florida I was like
look I can tell you in the summer it's
hot man it gets real hot he's like I'm
from Iran like I'm like okay we'll see
about that cool guy you know we go to a
party you remember the party the the
Bitcoin party the Jake Paul random
people are there
and I'm hot it's hot I'm like sweating
at the party Pat is there jacket um not
sweating whatsoever yeah and I'm just
like Pat you know you could take the
jacket off you're like is it hot out
it's just me you don't sweat bro no and
I'm Middle Eastern I should sweat it
yeah you know this is ancestral tenant
six you know even though it's cold this
is all about thermal pressures we
evolved with thermal pressures since the
beginning now we have something called a
thermostat AC right or a heater to
mitigate that you know comfort's not
good for the organism but we found a way
to make it comfortable yeah all the time
so when it's 160 degrees like you know
if you've never been exposed to 160
degrees and and you probably know a
little bit about extreme vasodilation
and vasoconstriction this is what our
blood vessels do and they need to go for
this kind of exercise but so few people
do this and it's accessible to everybody
right so if it's hot as [ __ ] get outside
you know and don't just do it once you
know if it's really cold get outside
when we're it sounds funny to say this
but we were when we were in New York
this morning
um I'm thinking okay how am I going to
get cold today and you could take a cold
shower in New York yeah you can yeah you
could take a cold so so these are things
you take a cold shower you feel like a
million bucks man you feel so good after
that and again this is accessible to
everybody you know like if there's a
time one thing I've learned through this
you know I think is just like to really
be myself
um many times I've woken up in the
morning and I'll go outside to do good
morning primals get the Sun and the
Earth my good morning primals it's time
and and you know what sometimes I didn't
really actually feel like it was prime
time you know so I'm gonna go get cold
and here's the thing you go get cold and
you there's nothing like it you know you
feel like a million bucks you know I
can't tell you how many people I've
talked to
um that can't get out of bed that and if
they can't get out of bed they can't get
out of their house like go start with a
cold shower tell me how you feel email
me right after the cold shower most of
the time oh couldn't do it yeah couldn't
do it okay start with hot just get
really hot and then turn into cold for
30 seconds and then tell me how you feel
again this is accessible to everybody
you know these thermal pressures confer
so many massive Fitness benefits and
Longevity benefits accessible to
everybody no one's going to financially
gain you know from this well maybe
people are selling cold plunges today
I'm not one of them yeah you know and
also saunas but we have these natural
thermal pressures that are available to
everybody you know so um I'm glad that
you guys brought this up because I
wanted to be able to plug that ancestral
tenant awesome but by the way just you
said wake up get some sun what time do
you wake up what time are you what's
your morning routine what's time you get
in the sun like just real quick I want
to know just like do you say like good
morning uh caveman like whatever your
little tree was pretty much walk us
through that would you yeah so uh I get
out of bed just before the sun comes up
you know the the sun is about get that
that's I don't even know what time that
usually is so there are probably six
five fifty six okay but it depends you
know what time of the year it is so it's
like okay if the sun's getting up so am
I and then the first thing I do is I
start to I get my phone and I go outside
and I record it every morning good
morning primals it's prime time to start
the day here's my win from the previous
day I'm sharing my win you better share
your win back this is how we create the
winning mindset the winning ecosystem if
you have any negative nancies you tell
them to hold we're sharing wins right
now and now it's prime time to to stack
the sun in the Earth get the Sun On You
Through The Eyes on the face on the skin
this is going to set your bio circadian
rhythm so your body and brain know when
to be alert in awake versus sleepy and
sleeping get your bare feet connected
anchored rounded into the Earth and you
don't have to do it for 20 30 minutes
right two minutes is better than none
exactly five minutes is better than two
just some connection to the Earth and
then I go piss on my favorite tree
[ __ ] a toilet toilet toilet and then I
get into the gym you know and that's my
what time are you in the gym uh it's
usually between seven seven thirty so
that's your morning you're doing Primal
stuff you're walking in the sand you're
you know he's a man's man dude by the
way when you go piss on this tree is
this tree now one of these Yosemite
types
by the way your neighbors you have
neighbors that see you there there's
Brian again pissing on that tree just we
love talking about himself acreage
I'd be remiss if I didn't ask you about
the beard bro I mean how long you've
been growing that thing what are you
what are you hiding under there you know
what I don't even know what's under
there I don't even know you know I mean
it gets long and liver Queen takes a
machete to it and we make a little video
okay it's time for a trim you know she
does the hair she does this and um and
it's great because I mean it's not easy
to cut with a machete and it just feels
great to have her doing that and a lot
of it's for the content too it's like
okay let's do that
um it's usually once or twice a year
she'll take a trip to it so you do trim
the beard oh yeah this is weird but is
that the only place you trim I don't do
I do no trimming okay no trimming no
shaving nothing on the chat they asked
me this morning uh if you if I I shave
my back or if I wax my back I'm like no
no and listen Hey listen if you want to
do that fine yeah help him out here but
I'm actually it's weird my brother's
hairy in the back and weird you're out
of the Middle East and his hair all over
your background patches I got lucky I
got no no hair yeah
on his back he looks like he's related
to a gorilla
like in the studio
he will say he will proudly say that's
because I'm a real man it's great 100
but his son doesn't have no so you know
for for most Assyrians Middle Easterns
they're legit now for you you can grow
full-blown beard might be I can't you
can't no I don't have a dinner listen
this is this is uh you if you ever see I
did a couple videos when I had beards
just look at it I can't never seen you
with a beard you guys are gifted man you
guys have I used to see you with a great
full head of hair like a week ago then
you said screw it I'm going with this
haircut man delicious haircut is where
I'm at right now I like it short yeah by
the way
Brian anything with you
where like are you one that goes to
bodybuilding shows are you one that
follows guys are you are you into it at
all like do you know the some of the
competitor no that's not even your world
I know some of the older guys you know
that I know Ronnie Coleman got it you
know I know Jay Cutler yep I know a lot
of these guys okay I don't follow any
got his guys today I think Ronnie is in
Dallas by the way I know he made a video
about me about if my abs are real or not
I mean this actually became a thing you
know that if I had real labs and then if
I had AB etching done and all this
ridiculous stuff you know and uh what
does your apps feel like like if
somebody touches her right now it just
feels like muscle here's the thing I
mean I'm flexing my abs right now I mean
I have I have my shirt off yeah I'm
flexing my he's been flexing this whole
time no you can't not have your shirt on
it's not a joke I'm more comfortable
flexing my abs now than not flexing my
eyes so you're flexing right now as we
speak I'm flexing my abs that's so funny
that's right so you feel my abs are
gonna feel hard look our friend that we
spoke to before the show I don't know if
we want to give a shout out or not but
he has one question he said ask the
liver King about his abs and if they're
real 100 they have to be real that was
his one question our buddy who is a big
bodybuilder guy oh he's a bodybuilder
yeah well that's a crazy thing I would
think any bodybuilder would actually
know would actually know yeah you know
like if you have AB implants or chest
and why would Ronnie say though Ronnie's
like the ultimate I think his team said
hey let's make a video and Ronnie ends
up saying okay I saw his abs move here I
think he ends up saying it gives me His
blessings yeah the king gave me his
blessings you know you know what like
just so you know I've never heard of
like uh uh implants for apps although
there's implants for episode nowadays
are [ __ ] there's implants for everything
if you want implants you can figure out
a way to get implants today go down to
Miami yeah but you'll see a lot of it if
there is like implants that you always
hear about you hear about calves and
plan you hear about shoulders what
they're doing to their shoulders
nowadays I don't know if you've heard
the story with shoulders shoulder
implants oh yeah adults the stuff they
put there for the dust like you know
some couple guys got criticized for that
but it's typically yeah wow calves
implants is what you get in triceps you
know there was a time in high school
this guy had incredible calves and at
the gym I remember saying to him holy
[ __ ] man like what do you do and he goes
and he grabbed it and he goes oh these
are implants and I started laughing like
of course with the jokes
um and now he goes no these are implants
holy [ __ ] and there's no way yeah yeah
bodybuilder I don't know no I don't
think no no way no way he had a great uh
physique but
um you know I I don't think you could
probably do
I have implants and have them actually
look good
yeah I don't think so either what are
you googling right now I've been playing
I've been plans you could tell like that
does not belong on that guy what is that
that guy like you know something like
that you could you'd be able to tell bro
very interesting that's pretty weird
that like that guy right there in the
middle that looks insane that's
hilarious by the way if you go a little
bit lower I'm worried what other
implants will show up so Rob don't do
this because HR will contact you yeah
liver King you know we're having fun now
we kind of got over the the tough part
and then you've been very transparent as
Pat said you shed a tear at one point
you kept it real that's awesome
and I know we're ending the the podcast
pretty soon overall what's your your
message right now you're you're on
you're on the circuit you're kind of
giving the apology tour
you're going through this cathartic
moment where you're telling the truth
you must be feeling some type of way
what's what's your overall message
My overall message as far as like what
you want the people to take from you at
this point yeah okay at this point
because but my overall message is my
truth no not that we've got that um
right now I would just say um I know
that I [ __ ] it up
I know that I what I did was wrong you
know I lied to people and I misled
people
um I own that and um there's nothing
else that I've lied about there's
nothing that I'm going to lie about I
feel like I've had this opportunity to
come clean like I'd better come as
[ __ ] clean as I can let's clean the
whole skeleton all the everything out of
the closet because I'm like I I get this
chance to do this in my mind I'm like I
better do that right now
um so my message is I want to take every
opportunity really again to apologize
you know and to own it and to say I'm
going to lead myself to be a better
human
respect uh if if the audience is
watching this you get to pick and choose
whatever you want to do and whatever
angle you go with it
um I I don't know I feel sincerity I
felt straight up and this is not an easy
thing to do and uh from here you know as
a the the challenge with these types of
things is when you do this and then
other things come out and other things
comes out and other things comes at the
incredibility fully takes a shot you
know that's why you get a chance to do
this and put everything on the line like
if anything like all of a sudden six
months from now oh the ABS are also this
this email came out with the surgeon now
you're really good but just so you know
if an email from a doctor comes out
saying I did the ab what do you call it
the the uh uh implants dude you are like
yeah you know it's gonna be ugly if that
happens just so you know you know what I
I bring it on yeah no all I'm saying is
all I'm saying is in in a situation like
this when you're going through it right
now it's like here's what's out there
outside of this dude this is what I'm
dealing with here's what I got let her
rip let's go and move on uh you know and
and the audience can you know like the
relationship with the fan and you
they're gonna go through it I'm gonna
put you in contact with the guys that I
talk to privately I'm not even going to
disclose who I put you in contact with
these guys won't even know who they're
going to be I'm just going to text you
and them you guys can talk and it'll be
between you myself and the other guys
that I put you in contact with you feel
comfortable telling people and they feel
comfortable like they're telling people
great but that's between you and them to
release that to people by the way Pat is
absolutely right by the way what he's
saying is abstract because in politics
that they call the drip campaign all
right we're gonna release this boom all
right let's see if they break boom we're
gonna at least see if they break boom so
I think if you're if you're if you're
clearing out the closet you'll be good
now if I find out that beard is fake get
liver cancer
Scooby-Doo just rips it off it was old
man Withers but but anyways look uh uh
sometimes uh this is what I told one
time when I was sitting down with a
couple of guys that you know know
they're going through what they're going
through with their family and all of a
sudden some public humiliation you go
through if the wife sticks around family
sticks around no one knows you better
than those people okay all the other
people in the world they think they know
you they know you 20 they know you 30
percent your wife and your kids pretty
much know you 70 80 we all still have a
little bit so you can try to make
everybody happy what matters is really
out there and if you're staying true
you're being straight up and eventually
people are going to be like you know
what whatever listen the guy looks good
he's busting his ass he works out he
does this he does that more power to him
respect to the guy so appreciate you for
coming out okay this was I know I I
don't know if your team rap who reached
out to who I don't know how they're
because you all of a sudden came up and
we were talking about liver King this
came out oh Allen yeah we've reached
yeah yeah got it so we and we we were I
think we were trying to do like four
months ago to eat the liver because I
actually freaking love liver yeah and
the fact that you came here today
without liberal I was disappointed
because I was planning on eating liver
tonight right you know what I wanted to
be clear to not plug really my time I
get that yeah I get I get the fact that
today's conversation was that but next
time you come here please bring some
liver because I actually I can overdose
on liver that's how much I love it
if you want if you want I'll bring some
liver like real if you genuinely if you
only knew how much I love liver I had no
idea dude are you kidding me catch are
you crazy so there's a city in Iran
called caraj and not even because
there's all Bali all Bali
can you put OB Ali Iran OB ali uh Ali
let me just see how you spell it yeah
exactly
no no let me see because that's probably
he wrote Albany
so funny let me see if I can put it up
Ali jigar Iran let's see if I can figure
this part about uh uh uh there's a city
in Iran you would go to obali and then
you would have this liver oh my God to
die for I mean when I tell you to die
for the Iranians they make it with the
spirit and then you put it and you put
the thing on and it was I'm hungry I
don't want to go home anyway
and they put like onions and they put
the seasoning on it and you know what's
Wild is so we just got back from
Mongolia and uh we had a traditional
dinner and the dinner had a skewer with
a piece of liver I was convinced that
this next piece was onion but it was it
was lamb tail fat oh [ __ ] but it was the
most succulent
you've ever had and and we had a Simo
Champion there with us and he asked me
to cut him a piece of liver I cut him a
piece of liver I gave it to him and he
went in to get some fat to pair yeah it
sounds pretty similar though it's pretty
it's pretty damn close and you know what
I'm not sick because I know we're about
to wrap it up and uh like always coming
clean and always being honest I think
this this podcast made me and I I
because I know I just want to come clean
talk about that I have fake I have blood
implants so you know
and by the way no one in my house likes
liver and caviar and those are the two
things like I can overdose on my dad
likes caviar a little bit I love caviar
I eat caviar like it's like ice cream
it's how much I love that and Kevin
you know this is such a big deal to me a
lot of people ask me about okay what are
the three things in business you can do
you know to start kicking ass in
business I'm like hold on a second
you've missed all the fundamental things
are you eating liver right and if you're
not eating liver right I'm like do you
know how many fundamental things you can
do to kick ass in life that will allow
you to scale and Lead better in business
and when I say that my name is liver
King because liver is King I know I
can't do this by myself I need a hundred
people that are also the liver King
promoting liver and so now that we've
talked about this now it's official
you're the ever King
you are the liver kid congratulations
There It Is Well the Liverpool anointed
liver cancer
oh my God truth has been revealed it's
the Iranian liver King is here but
please take opportunities in the future
you know that this is nourishment that
we've had in our DNA since the beginning
of our time we've recently removed this
nourishment from our bodies and when you
reintroduce it this is why I love taking
it on the podcast because you give this
nourishment to somebody and within 30
minutes they start to feel something and
it's like
Pat if you show up here tomorrow no
shirt on walking through
usually go everywhere just yoked up it's
amazing here's what I think we do I I
think literally one of these home team
podcasts okay we make Liberty got
outside and we bring it here please and
we eat please do you know how to make it
if we secure it 100 you know how to make
the skewer and everything don't do
everything you and my dad are
responsible okay I'm gonna eat because
uh you know it's gonna be on YouTube not
too cooked
medium rare is how I like it okay
fantastic well you try some rare by
itself
okay I'm all in okay yeah and Pat I'll
bring the Jewish chop liver from the
deli don't Street we're good to go and
guys I might not be around but I would
like an invitation
it delivers on the table up there
anyways uh my man awesome again thanks
for coming out this was fantastic bro
and I'm sure the audience uh uh enjoyed
it just as much as we did and that we're
looking forward to seeing what's going
to happen with the next chapter of liver
King it's exciting to see what you do
next I think I gang if you enjoyed it
um uh uh give us a sub you know give us
a thumbs up at the same time we're going
to put the link below to your website
that you're doing as well uh Rob let's
make sure you put that below as well
Malik uh to find more information about
what he's got going on and uh stay tuned
we got more crazy things coming here
very soon take care everybody bye bye
bye bye-bye